foreign
Chicago what's up Ben
all right
excellent what's up man how can I help
all right so a lot of context here I'll
try to get through as much as I can but
my fiance who I'll call my wife for the
call just because by the time this airs
we'll be getting married in a couple
weeks from now and it's two or syllable
so that makes it easier for both of us
um congratulations yeah thank you we got
it home about nine months ago and it's
our first home that we've ever had so
obviously when you get a new home
there's a lot you can read about there's
a lot you can learn but there's a lot
that you don't know and you learn a lot
of the first time home buyer lessons
and unfortunately one of those lessons
recently came up so
uh last week I was about 40 miles away
trained boxing at my old gym uh the wife
was at home and a couple blocks away
from us there's like a commercial
district with a vape shop and that shop
had gotten shot up there about seven or
eight shots that were fired uh gun
unplug the scene no one's really sure
where they went but obviously from my
home you could hear the gunshots you
could then have a see how the cops come
all the cop cars were within a view and
because he had put the scene the cops
were running around looking through all
the yards including hours to see if they
could find a gunman
so I wasn't aware that this was
happening as it was happening because I
was at the gym about 40 miles away my
phone was in my bag because I'm
obviously not checking my phone while
I'm training
and when I finished up checked my phone
saw that my wife had dealt with all this
and was very rattled by it and so it
sort of was the situation where for her
she she has a lot of concerns where she
felt unsafe I was pretty sure just based
on what I came on it but she wasn't in
any danger sure especially not by the
time that I heard about it so I wasn't
as concerned about that at the point at
that point but I did feel as though
having a house for nine months that I'd
really miss an opportunity to really do
my job and do my part is kind of the man
of the house and really help protect the
house have a plane in place in case
anything happens so she knew what to do
or if I was there I would know exactly
what to do
um to actually have like the right
equipment if needed to protect ourselves
because at the moment we are currently
on our dog really all we really have is
um pepper spray and some kitchen knives
you say the right equipment like get a
bunch of guns
um I don't know if they need a bunch
necessarily but guns are definitely
automatically yeah part of your
equipment the way the way you said
equipment I was thinking like we're
gonna get some rakes and a shovel and a
pitch for it uh but you're talking about
getting a gun okay
yeah okay yeah so so I'm pretty familiar
with a lot of like combat stuff like as
I kind of headed there like I was doing
boxing like I've been in Combat Sports
for a while and as much as I would love
to just handle everything hand to hand I
feel like it's the best way to do and
you can use Elite Sports necessary uh
the most important thing in a fight is
range and there is nothing to better
range of that gun you could take the
scariest guy say Mike Tyson asked me if
I'd fight him for a million dollars I'd
say no ask me if I fight him from 50
yards away with a gun in my hand and he
has none I'd probably win that fight
because that's effectively
the Tower of one of those tools and so
if somebody is coming to my home to do
harm and has one of them and I don't
um it's potentially gonna be a very bad
day not just for me but for my family
and especially if I'm not home and
I'm not there to protect
so having that scared to me it just kind
of reinforces that it would be a very
wise move to have a weapon uh if needed
um the odds of it being necessary aren't
incredibly high but in the event that it
does happen it would be very important
to have
uh but that's where the problem begins
so
um my wife uh comes from a left-wing
background her family's very left-wing
and she's kind of got like a visceral
fear of having a gun like just doesn't
it's not so much like
like it to her it's like the idea of
having a gun in our home is just that
she's very uncomfortable with not only
because of the fact that the gun is
effectively a death machine but also
because
like actually seeing it sort of like it
tells you that there is a potential for
harm out there is that
back on maybe news one day so she's
incredibly uncomfortable with it so it
puts me in a spot where if I feel like
it's my job to protect the home
I have to decide do I
if I'm unable conventor and obviously
the correct answer here is to lay out a
great case where she she relents and
says okay
this is the right move and I'm on board
with it but if I'm not able to do that
because it's going to be a lot of work
that's going to be needed for that do I
either a
go with her wishes and not get the gun
and we just don't have it or be
potentially end up in a situation where
the gun would have been a thing that
would have saved us but we didn't get it
because I went against my better
judgment and then something really bad
happens
all right let me hop in here
um
first uh let's I want to get rid of the
left wing right wing framing okay all of
us grew up in homes that give us
particular strengths and particular
baggage that we bring into the home that
we get married we're creating on our own
okay so I don't want her to I don't want
you to settle her and I don't want her
to settle herself with well I grew up in
this Super Rat Wing home and we were pew
pew or this super left-wing home and we
didn't have I don't want any of that I
would rather her take ownership of how
she feels right now and you take
ownership of how you feel right now in
her home
in the home that she is creating with
you
um she does not feel comfortable having
a gun in your home in the home that you
are creating with her you don't feel
comfortable not having a gun in your
home
okay that let's frame let's start it
there because it keeps all the baggage
and all the smoke and it keeps all that
out of it because all of us regardless
of the homes we grew up in we have to
make choices about the homes that we are
going to create for ourselves Okay so
I'm gonna back all the way out of this
thing and then I'll answer your very
specific question okay is that cool yeah
you are feeling what you are feeling has
nothing to do with guns
okay you are feeling something terrible
and beautiful and terrifying all at the
same time can I tell you what it is
it's love
and the only way love works is if
somebody's vulnerable
somebody said you could hurt me and they
say and you could hurt me and that's how
we're gonna connect
okay it's taking the covers off the
plugs and actually
doing the scary thing of plugging in
okay
and what you were coming face to face
with
when you got done boxing right and I
trained for years like it feels good and
all hardcore and there's a very you know
what model my training all my years of
training and I train with people who are
in the UFC I train with all kind of
crazy
the years of training
a hundred percent of the time I will
walk away from a fight that's what I got
from my training I'm gonna walk away
it's not worth it and I don't know who's
got a who's gonna smash me in the head
with a hammer I don't know who's got a
gun point on me I'm walking away
your wife is well okay well knock your
lights out because I know my wife so
you'll have a great day I'm out of here
right so all that what you've come face
to face with is
you're not going to be able to protect
her all the time
and there's gonna come moments whether
it's in the car whether it's an office
mate whether it's a boss who's a jerk
whether it's her dad whether who her
older brother who knows whatever it is
you can't be everywhere all the time
and this is beyond the gun conversation
this is something you have to make peace
with this idea that I'm married or so I
got a protector
I want you to re-examine that
you do need to have a plan and that was
a good thing that came out of this
showing to sit down and say whoa what
are we going to do
right same as the first time something
catches on fire in a new in a in a
newlyweds new home and they're like oh
we don't have a fire drill like what do
we do
um or the sit down and do a will
together like who's gonna get the dog
and the kids when we die right
um those are all important so glad
you'll have a plan and part of your plan
might be having a gun great but above
that
there's something powerful that you need
to absorb
which is you cannot be everywhere all
the time for her 24 7 365. it's
impossible
and that is a burden you are putting on
yourself that's going to make you insane
it's going to make you mad okay if you
live in a home that is simply unsafe do
whatever you got to do to move
if you happen to be in a house where
there's a crime committed a couple of
blocks over and the police came and it
was unnerving yeah that's unnerving man
it's wild it's really unnerving
um that's something to absorb and feel
and then put that into your plan so is
are you tracking with me so far
yeah it's scary as hell to think
somebody can hurt my wife and I'm not
there is that true
yeah
yeah
I mean I understand I can't be there all
the time but I guess part of me is just
like if I'm not there then I just want
her to have the best chance possible and
there you go there you go they should
have a better chance that there was a
weapon and then if there wasn't that's
that's that's
uh potentially potentially
um
so answering beneath that
creating a safe environment for your
family we're going to have there'll be
debates on what the word safe means in
the comments of this thing I know
um if your wife tells you I can't sleep
if there's a gun in this house at this
moment I would recommend not overriding
her right now that doesn't that doesn't
sound like a loving move or a safe
overall move okay
um I would here's what I would do I
would create a what would we do plan
with your wife
and let's sit down and have some fun
with it like it may be a bite a couple
of your neighbors over like what would
we do if somebody showed up and started
filling the blank banging on the door
are we gonna answer the door we're gonna
call 9-1-1 like what would we do and
let's go through some of those things we
I live out in the country man
and my wife and I have had those
conversations and uh who do we call
where would we go we've talked to my
kids hey if I ever fall off a ladder
while you're here here's where you go
you're gonna go down the hill you're
gonna go across the creek to this guy's
house and so have that plan that's
awesome
um the second thing is I would invite
your neighbors over to your house
and y'all have an open conversation get
to know their names
okay that's gonna give your wife peace
that she is not isolated and maybe
having uh your neighbor's name or two or
three people she could call if something
sets off is going to be much more of a
gift than knowing there's a John Wick
gun in the drawer back there okay
Okay the third thing is if it's possible
and this sounds so cheesy and I know but
my dad was a cop so uh if you have a
conversation with the police uh invite
them over or have somebody go visit have
somebody swing by and just to develop a
relationship with them get the crime
stats for your area know how safe it is
where you live right that could be a
possible thing so let's get to the gun
part I am a
my dad was a homicide detective a SWAT
guy and I'm a Texan so I've got enough
guns in my house okay also my wife grew
up in Texas she was a competitive
shooter and she hates him she doesn't
like him
okay
um she's more of a statistician than me
and just looks at the data that more
people get hurt with their own guns than
they actually fight off Intruders
um and I don't know if that data is true
but that's it floats around out there so
here's what I would recommend
sit down with your wife and say hey
would you take a class with me
would you at least go to a range and try
and she might say absolutely not I will
not do that
okay
okay
um chances are she will
or would you take it it would make me
feel more secure if we just went to took
a class together
or would you feel more safe taking a
shotgun class which I think is a better
home defense weapon than a 45 or
whatever thing would
um
would you be willing to go do that with
me
I'm gonna take a class
I want to really know what I'm doing and
I want to know how this stuff works and
by the way even if you've done it your
whole life
I'm going to take a course
I would love it if you joined me
in that way it's much less I watched a
lot of movies and it's a lot more
I'm going to get trained on how to take
care of my family and keep everybody
safe
does that make sense
yeah I upload the idea around her I
guess just the idea of being in the
presence of one is kind of difficult but
absolutely
the more we talk about I think she'll
move around a little bit more we both
have the same goal we both wanted to
keep the family safe and not because we
don't have kids yet but that's something
we want to get started on soon so yeah I
think we have the same goal as just how
would you get there I think taking the
class
I think there's something to be gained
by taking a class
um
and
you can think about this all day long
it's not until you actually experience
it that there's any sort of
transformation I can talk about gun
safety all day long with my kids
um it's a very big deal to me that they
know exactly how these things work and
why they're so dangerous and why they're
to be revered and why they are very
specific tools for very specific moments
um and so I put I'm very intentional
with my kids I don't want it to be some
Dragon somewhere that they call upon
thinking because they watch some movies
right I want them to actually have seen
it and felt it and smelled it right
smelt it and I want them to have
experienced all of the the whole process
and now I've got a 12 year old little
boy that is in absolute reverence
he handles a weapon in my presence
better than adults I'm with
it's very impressive but it's through
years of just training right and High
High High intentionality
um and so I tell you to tell you I think
a class just talking about like yeah
yeah man that's not gonna that's not
gonna move the needle on the safety
conversation
actually saying hey I'm gonna go take a
class because I want to get good at this
I want to be very competent in that and
what you're going to find is very
similar to
um very similar to your boxing training
your martial arts training I was really
Cavalier my man really Cavalier
it was one of the first guys in Texas to
get the CHL when that was a thing and a
real Cavalier about the whole thing and
then I started going into homes and
helping police officers clean up suicide
scenes
I started going into homes to tell
mothers that their kids have been shot
and killed
I started running around I had a patrol
car that I went on patrol
and I got to see some things that really
changed my perspective on that similar
to I trained MMA and boxing all that
stuff
and I ended up fighting I ended up
walking I made me an infinitely more
peaceful guy
became very very able to take care of
myself which empowered me to then walk
away and it was when I got out of the
movies and started showing up to these
homes
and cleaning up scenes that will haunt
me for the rest of my life that I
made peace with oh man I'm gonna do
everything in my power
to create a safe home environment that
doesn't include
first offense right
because the reality of how that plays
out is gnarly now
can I take care of myself you better
believe it yes
I've trained and I still train
but I do those things so I don't have to
and I hope that that makes sense
I hope that makes sense
um
my promise to you is if y'all just ran
out today and bought a gun and put in
your house your wife would not feel
safer and statistically speaking y'all
wouldn't be quote unquote safer
if y'all go take classes and you learn
what to do and you have a plan of what
happens if somebody knocks on the door
if somebody beats the door and somebody
kicks in your car window whatever
now we've got a plan that we've
practiced that's where safety comes from
that's when your body goes okay we know
what to do
we know what to do so that's my
recommendation my brother thank you so
much for trusting me with a call
um good luck with your wedding hope
everything goes awesome and hope uh hope
she still wants to marry you after nine
months of living with you just kidding
hope she I hope it all works out great
man and thanks for calling thanks for
calling um this is a hard conversation
but I appreciate your trust